bienvenue à tous et leur de parlement
hebdo 45 minutes pour refaire l'aktu
politique et parlementaire avec a des
côtés dit qu'elle allait vous bonjour
elle n'est pas encore en discussion à
l'assemblée mais déjà très contesté à
droite comme à gauche la loi macron pour
relancer l'économie et la croissance a
été présenté en conseil des ministres le
ministre défend c'est toute la semaine
d'expliquer son texte et de déminer le
terrain
après l'assemblée le oui du sénat la
reconnaissance d'un état palestinien
symbolique
la proposition de résolution de la
gauche a été adopté mais de justesse 154
voix 1946 la droite était contre ce
texte
et puis le plus de l'hebdo cette semaine
chronique sur la montée de l'islam
radical chez les jeunes la
désintégration c'est le titre du
documentaire diffusé sur notre antenne
un documentaire qui tentent de
comprendre les raisons de cette dérive
on en parlera tout à l'heure et pour
commenter toute cette actualité nous
recevrons gilbert collard bonjour oui
bonjour vous êtes député non-inscrit
avec l'étiquette rassemblement le mari
n'oublie quechua pas remonter front
national à votre honneur
il faut être très clair en face masqué
je suis apparentés front national donc
je verse ma dotation au front national
mais je suis secrétaire
général du rassemblement bleu marine et
à ce titre je n'ai pas ma carte au front
national mais si marine demain me
demander de l'apprendre
j'aurais pas de mal à prendre vous
l'apprendrez en ciel me demande ma roue
il son problème oui mais attendez juste
parce que pour l'instant j'ai une
mission de rassemblement il ya des gens
qui viennent vers nous parce que
précisément je représente le
rassemblement bleu marine sans pour
autant représenter le front national
d'oka n'y a qu'un pas on est d'accord là
comme pas la tradition de cette émission
c'est que ce sont les parlementaires qui
dresse un petit peu votre portrait en
tout cas eu tellement de portraits voilà
une peine de vous je n'ai plus qu'à me
mouvoir sur écoutons-les que vos débats
très juste après sa place comme les
autres un bon c'est un adversaire
politique c'est clair mais il a été élu
par le suffrage universel il est donc
légitime comme tout un chacun des
députés quelle que soit leur pensée donc
je crois que là-dessus il ya ya ya rien
de dire presque y travaillent
moi je n'ai pas vu est excessivement
travaillé sur les textes en commission
des lois c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
il vient de temps en temps il nous fait
une petite sortie et puis il repart
voilà mais c'est surtout bon pour pour
montrer qu'il existait un élu de la
république qui a toute légitimité à
temps cet aspect là qui est en cause que
le fait d'être non inscrit qui ne permet
pas d'avoir non plus tout à fait les
moyens équivalents à ceux dont disposent
les groupes donc ça veut dire un temps
de parole différents une visibilité
différentes
et puis c'est aussi collard un tribun
kaka aussi un certain talent c'est un
bon juriste évidemment un
professionnellement il est connu donc il
choisi non pas ses clients mais il
choisit aussi ces sujets tous les
députés sont des députés quelle que soit
leur engagement politique que soient
leurs convictions politiques
moi je ne partage pas les convictions
politiques du gilbert que là c'était un
bon pénaliste un avocat avec des connus
l'envoi monté au créneau ce tomb des
questions des repas très très souvent et
puis n'oublie pas que c'était un des
premiers lieutenants de madame le pen
c'est cette qui soi-disant va
révolutionner la france avec des mesures
d' ultragauche 2
à gauche du front de gauche qui
apporteront non pas de la croissance et
de l'emploi mais plus de pauvreté
voilà pour la réaction n'est pas un
crime parce que c'est vrai vous êtes
avocat maître collard
tellement qu'on entend comme très
souvent à bokassa veut pas dire
invincible ça peut aider d'accord mais
la plupart des parlementaires qui était
avocat d'après ce que j'ai pu lire un
n'était pas de bons orateurs à la
tribune quentin qui par exemple qui a
été un très grand avocat
en tout cas les parlementaires de ce que
vous êtes ou lever un bon orateur qu'est
ce que vous pensez vous en tant
qu'avocat moment du rassemblement bleu
marine de la une d'un journal people qui
a décidé d'étaler la vie privée du
numéro 2 du front national florian
philippot
il a été ajouté par ce journal est ce
que vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
qu'à côté de vous avocat et membre du
rassemblement l'hommage et j'ai twitté
closer water closet voilà alors je crois
que j'ai tout dit en quelques mots c'est
très grave ce qui se passe parce que il
n'y a plus aucune vie privée quand je
dis voilà et ça c'est un signe de
déliquescence éthique sociale vous ne
vous appartenez plus je m'appartient
plus vous non plus dès l'instant où vous
avez un seuil de notoriété qui fait de
la rentabilité bon alors moment on me
dit mais quand c'était françois hollande
qui s'est fait choper vous étiez bien
heureux c'est vrai c'est vrai mais c'est
différent quand on est et non justement
qu'il en est et où le dire bon je vous
dis c'est vrai que quand on a vu que
hollande ce sont ceux son casque se
faire choper on sait tous ce marais mais
c'est quand même le président de la
république je lis rebond alors qu'il y
ait des atteintes à la vie privée du
président de la république ça peut se
comprendre mais quand on est membre d'un
parti qu'on occupe des fonctions
ah oui tout à fait c'est la faute contre
nous si les juges n'était pas terrorisé
par la commission européenne
il y eut par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme dont ils
sanctionnerait il faut qu'ils régulation
des dates bien sûr mais le problème
c'est que au niveau de l'arrêt de son
avocat non parce qu'on n'a pas le droit
en tant que parlementaire de plaisir et
faire de presse
mais si les juges condamnés à des
amendes plus lourdes que le bénéfice
rapporté par l'indiscrétion par
l'atteinte à la vie privée les journaux
ne le ferai plus mais mais c'est
beaucoup plus rentable de vous
lire que de payer une contravention elle
est repassée le rêve de l'actuelle
n'entrent dans le vif de l'actualité
politique avec lundi le front national
qui renforce ses positions sur le
territoire le scrutin a eu lieu dans la
troisième circonscription de l'autre
pour succéder à françois baroin devenu
sénateur le candidat du ps a été éliminé
résultat un second tour qui oppose le
front national à l'ump
gilbert collard le fn a donc gagné ce
premier tour mais avec plus de 75 %
d'abstention donc une faible
mobilisation vote de rejet puisque
d'adhésion c'est toujours là c'est tous
les politologues s'amuse à s'interroger
sur est ce que c'est un vote de rejet
est ce que c'est un vote d'adhésion
on sait pas comment voulez vous savoir
personne ne peut entrer dans cette
alchimie donc sur les 15% d'abstentions
free phénomène mais ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que la france traverse une
crise politique majeure
les citoyens ne s'y retrouvent plus dans
la république il ne s'y retrouvent plus
dans leurs élus voilà ce que ça veut
dire mais ça ne signifie pas pour autant
que nous mais l'ensemble bien compris
oui probablement parce que c'est une
vision holistique prendre loyal terme de
sociologie 1
les gens ne font pas la différence bon
et c'est dommage parce que vous avez des
hommes politiques qui se crèvent très
honnêtement eia alors c'est quand même
aussi un facteur médiatique regarder
woerth tout le mal qu'on a dit de lui et
moi je pense à lui voyez vous on n'a pas
les même si dans ce combat mais cet
homme a été salie salies si on reprend
tous les journaux télévisés si on
reprend tous les journaux publiés et
qu'on dit à chaque journaliste et
maintenant qu'est-ce que tu réponds
alors il ya aussi cette espèce de de
lynchage médiatique est permanente et
aujourd'hui on ensemble les élus
mais aujourd'hui il faut éviter la
suspicion vous comprenez c'est à dire
que dès l'instant où on porte contre
vous une accusation comme à l'époque des
sycophantes dans la grèce antique à un
moment la démocratie allait mourir
vous êtes accusé donc vous êtes coupable
ça c'est horrible quoi parce que
n'importe qui peut être accusé par
n'importe qui on va passer cette fois au
mardi avec le sénat qui a voté le budget
et on en parle parce que ça faisait que
longtemps que le sénat n'avait pas voté
le budget depuis presque deux ans avant
ça le mérite quand même d'être soulignée
le projet de loi de finances a été
examinée jusqu'au bout et voter un texte
évidemment remaniée par la droite
sénatoriale et à l'assemblée il ya eu
des débats animés sur le droit d'asile
un projet de loi prévoit de raccourcir
les délais de traitement des dossiers
d'offrir un meilleur accueil
la droite porte le fer sur les déboutés
du droit d'asile regarder ce sujet
signée mario lefebvre becker améliorer
l'accueil des demandeurs d'asile
renforcer l'attractivité de la france et
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
ce sont les objectifs de la réforme du
droit d'asile sous pression de l'europe
le premier enjeu c'est de réduire le
délai d'examen des demandes d'asile de
deux ans aujourd'hui à 9 mois
l'accélération des délais s'impose à
tous et à l'administration d'abord qui
doit recueillir la demande d'asile dans
les trois jours qui suivent l'arrivée en
france d'une personne aujourd'hui des
familles entières peuvent attendre
jusqu'à sept mois par exemple en région
parisienne avant de pouvoir déposer leur
demande d'asile
et pendant ces sept mois elles sont sans
toit sans droit sans titre en france les
demandeurs d'asile seront également
mieux accompagner et bénéficieront de
meilleures conditions d'accueil
elles seront en revanche plus directive
enfin de mieux répartir l'effort sur
l'ensemble du territoire
nous prévoyons de mettre en place une
orientation directives des demandeurs
d'asile mieux orienter leur accueil
permettra également de mieux les
accompagner de leur offrir de meilleures
conditions d'hébergement pour
l'opposition si le texte est paré de
bonnes intentions
le gouvernement fait preuve de naïveté
sur le détournement du droit d'asile
d'autres procédures d'asile à bout de
souffle s'est transformé en véritable
machine à légaliser des clandestins la
demande d'asile est devenue une
procédure légale pour l'immigration
illégale en 2013
la france comptait près de 65 mille
demandeurs d'asile pour étudier leur
dossier en neuf mois et les accueillir
correctement il faudra plus
moyens préviennent déjà les associations
à l'assemblée nationale gilbert collard
ce ce débat sur le droit d'asile a
souvent dévié vers un débat sur
l'immigration est ce que vous faites
vous aussi l'amalgamé vous souhaitez
offrir mieux la tribune oui oui je vous
fais là l'amalgamme parce que 80% de
débouter 5% seulement d'expulser c'est
quand même un chiffre qui fait réfléchir
on a appris notamment que des sans abri
ne pouvait pas se loger parce que
c'était des demandeurs d'asile en
attente qui occupaient les lieux
donc ça pose un vrai problème et le com
de toute manière on n'est pas en
situation de les expulser ça devient de
l'immigration c'est indiscutable le le
chiffre a été évoqué à l'assemblée
nationale et n'a pas été contestée sur
les 80 % de développer parce que c'est
la 5 % de raccompagner mois selon vous
le gouvernement a décidé de dissocier ce
texte droit d'asile et d'immigration
mais on a mis les sociétés politiques
ils le disent aussi pas ils le disent
aussi parce que toute manière ça donne
dans les textes ça entre dans un dans un
service qui relie à l'immigration donc
il faut pas qu'ils nous prennent pour
des pour des imbéciles
mais il ne veut pas enclenché la
polémique parce qu'il sait très bien que
la question de l'immigration est très
très très très préoccupante
et comme il sait que malheureusement le
droit d'asile est devenu un moyen de
contourner les règles sur l'immigration
il ne veut pas dire quand vous pensez
qu'un demandeur d'asile pendant qu'il
attend il un logement il a des
allocations il à dz et les demandeurs de
les demandeurs d'asile ceux qui auront
l'asile ou avoir droit à un emploi
également est ce que ça veut dire que la
france pour parler clairement doit
rompre sa tradition de terre d'accueil
madame la france veut vendre tous ses
aéroports et nous aurons le coeur beau
on sera sien on trouve tout et
secondaire d'accueil c'est fini a
déclaré monsieur moi je suis ton qu'on
accueille la terre entière voilà à
condition qu'on en ait les moyens
si je dois vendre tous mes meubles mon
livre la plus les moyens de croire que y
ira quoi si je dois me retrouvais mois à
la rue pour que les autres n'y soit pas
avec ma famille donc ccc dufau
libournais ont jeudi personne personne
n'est méchant fondamentalement machiko
comme comme vous je voudrais qu'on
puisse accueillir toute la misère du
monde mais en vendre deux aéroports
troisième a pas les moyens
bon alors des fautes raisonnable je
crois j'aimerais que la honte
et on va retourner au sénat si vous
voulez bien il a rendu une visite au
député national hier je parle de nicolas
sarkozy il est venu ce mardi devant le
groupe parlementaire ump au sénat au
menu évidemment le rassemblement
centriste mais aussi des questions des
primaires et c'était moi j'avais une
question très précise à vous poser on a
appris via paris match que nicolas
sarkozy s'était rendu au qatar il ya une
semaine pour donner une conférence
rémunérés il en a le droit
totalement est ce qu'aujourd'hui selon
vous il doit encore pouvoir le faire en
tant que président de parti ne ronge
repas jeux repas alors c'est sûr que si
monsieur hollande veut faire des
conférences il ne sera pas payé de la
même manière on peut le penser
bon qu'ils aillent faire des conférences
et qu'ils soient payés chacun fait ce
qu'il veut un bon mois quand j'allais
faire des conférences je demandais
comment sont des pléiades
c'est comme ça que j'ai une très belle
collection de claix yade mais bon c'est
pas c'est pas très coûteux
je conseille rien de nouveau je
conseillerais dare-dare était d'arrêter
ce soit au qatar ça vous choque pas mais
je sais pas les 1 je reste quand je
reçois une invitation du qatar je n'y
vais pas pourquoi parce que je pense que
ce pays joue un rôle très trouble dans
les problèmes que nous rencontrons avec
le terrorisme et j'ai pas envie de
déjeuner avec ce qui pourrait être le
diable je suis prudent même avec une
très longue cuillère qatar c'est des
liaisons dangereuses pour vous et je
pense je pense je pense que le qatar
l'arabie saoudite joue un rôle qui n'est
pas très clair et qui est dénoncé du
reste un vous avez plein d'études plein
d'articles qui le disent
et je pense que c'est pas un bon signe
que nicolas sarkozy même pour de
l'argent même si largeur à l'odeur du
pétrole puisque ont dit qu'il n'a pas
d'odeur
l'ajfer une conférence là-bas rémunéré
alors mardi toujours serre cela j'arrive
et je retrouve la liberté après trois
ans de captivité l'otage français retenu
aux mains d'al qaïda au maghreb
islamique des questions se posent sur
les conditions de cette libération
éternelle question
officiellement la france ne verse aucune
rançon et % personne n'est dupe vous
vous dites quoi
jeudi que le principe réaffirmé doit
être qu'on ne verse pas de rançon
parce que chaque fois qu'on verse une
rançon en alimente le preneur d'otage de
demain c'est tout simple c'est un
mécanisme criminologique est
parfaitement étudiée dès l'instant où
l'on cède aux maîtres chanteurs
en alimente sans chantage dès l'instant
où l'on cède à un preneur d'otages ont
créé des preneurs d'otages voilà alors
on en sauve un mais on va en perdre peut
être deux ou trois ou quatre et il
arrivera un moment là aussi où on ne
pourra plus payer
alors je crois qu'il vaut mieux avoir un
échange de prisonniers les champs de
prisonniers c'est différent le goal et
c'est facile aussi de parler comme ça en
homme d'état là sur son sur son sommet
quand c'est pas votre père c'est par
votre mère c'est par votre frère c'est
pas votre soeur bon il faut en tout cas
il faut quoi qu'on fasse quoi qu'on
fasse qu'on ait une position de fermeté
c'est à dire que si on était amené à
payer eh bien ça ne doit pas savoir la
discrétion vos dents c'est la discrétion
vous moi je suis pour qu'on ne paye pas
parce que j'ai une position de fermeté
je suis pour que l'on fasse payer
autrement militairement mais je
considère que si l'on paye en alimente
des vocations de terroristes c'est ce
qu'ils font du racisme benjamin est très
simple on prend un otage on médiatise on
sait que la démocratie est fragile on
fait un chantage médiatique et on est
payé quoi son c'est c'est ce sont des
hold-up humanitaire c'est c'est
insupportable de cds que françois
hollande peut tirer un bénéfice
politique de cette libération
honorons je crois pas je crois pas parce
que les gens savent très bien comment ça
fonctionne maintenant break puis est-ce
qu'il est encore en situation le pauvre
de tirer bénéfice de quoi que ce soit
c'est dire qu on est là maître collard
on peut au moins faire crédit au
président de la république d'avoir mis
fin
enfin qu'il n'y ait plus d'otages mais
français mais aussi ses décisions tous
employés ils savent très bien que c'est
très usant de la fai oui mais bon on
s'en félicite
c'est très serré c'est très bénéfique
mais dans quelles conditions voilà alors
ça a été fait encore dans des conditions
favorables sur les conditions voila
voila et ça c'est dommage quoi c'est
dommage
alors passez au mercredi c'est le jour
de présentation de la loi des manuels
macro
sacrée journée pour le ministre de
l'économie a qui présentait à cette
crise qui vise à libérer la croissance
le matin une conférence de presse avec
manuel valls est pas moins de dix
ministres pour l'auto et l'après midi et
bien la traditionnelle séance de
questions d'actualité à l'assemblée
plutôt animé le film de la journée on
regarde tout ça journée marathon pour
emmanuel macron 10 heures présentation
du projet de loi activités et croissance
en conseil des ministres cent six
articles et onze ministres mobilisés
pour expliquer le texte
manuel valls est en première ligne nous
devons donner de l'énergie à notre
société
déverrouiller les blocages alléger les
contraintes
bref soutenir la croissance l'activité
le travail et le risque au détriment de
la rente de l'immobilisme et du
conservatisme un texte qui provoque des
remous jusque dans la majorité en
particulier sur une disposition
l'extension du travail le dimanche le
texte autorise les commerces à ouvrir
jusqu'à douze dimanches par an contre
cinq actuellement
c'est trop pour le parti socialiste on
ne peut pas aller sur un chiffre aussi
élevé le parti socialiste où est ce que
souhaite qu'on revienne à une exception
du travail le dimanche et c'est un
retour vers 5 ou 7 15 heures questions
au gouvernement dans l'hémicycle
interrogé sur ce projet de loi le
ministre de l'économie monte au front
opération pédagogie face aux députés ce
projet de loi vous l'avez dit vise avant
tout à accroître l'activité et la
croissance dans notre pays
c'est une loi qui compte tenu de
l'urgence justement refuse la posture
refuse l'idée magique pour aborder
chacun des leviers concret qui pourrait
avoir un impact réel ce matin un projet
de loi a été présenté qui est concret
qui portent des mesures concrètes qui
répondent aux préoccupations de ses
entreprises monsieur le député au même
moment salle des quatre colonnes
à droite comme à gauche le projet de loi
macron fait grincer des dents la loi
macron c'est un véritable scandale c'est
une mystification total on a vu la
gauche se radicaliser sur cette histoire
de dimanche comme 6,5 7 12 dimanche ça
allait changer la nature de l'économie
française gouvernement n'est même pas
aisé de chiffré en termes d'emplois ce
que ça pourrait représenter les
discussions sur le texte commenceront le
22 janvier
les débats s'annoncent tendues pour
l'heure chacun semble bien décidé à
camper sur ses positions
oui beaucoup de choses dans cette loi
mâcon mais c'est vrai que ce qui
cristallise un petit peu les
mécontentements c'est le travail du
dimanche mais plutôt 512 époque le
travail de voir cette loi n'a pas encore
n'ont pas encore n est pas encore
revenue en dix ans de bons débats
d'abord il faut là mais on en n'a pas
encore des bastions de la fin janvier à
l'assemblée relevé en janvier donc on va
examiner article par article là il va
aller voir mon avis à une bière
d'amendements qui va durer et ses lois
fortes ou pour vous écouter il suffit
d'écouter le premier ministre en parle
et si on faisait une études
sémiologiques c'est des mots creux c'est
ce qu'on appelle des mots valises
il n'y a pas un élément concret dans son
discours je vais prendre l'exemple des
ddd d'un domaine que je connais bien bon
et on arrive pas on n'arrive pas à
comprendre ce qu il veut quoi bon alors
il va ouvrir le capital des sociétés
d'avocats
merki aux banques alors on nous dit que
ça sera réservé aux professionnels
mais c'est pas mal c'est pas c'est pas
écrit que c'est mal formés j'ai
l'impression que on a voulu donner des
gages à bruxelles qu'on était capable de
faire des réformes et on cherche on
cherche lui reste un an cherche le moyen
de 22 cadavres d'abeilles est quoi cette
volonté mais ce qu'on essaie de faire
des réformes qui ne veulent pas de cette
loi disent que c'était pour faire
plaisir à bruxelles salvatori qu'on
attendait ça c'est vrai que ça oui
d'accord avec ça parce que encore une
fois bon va supprimer par exemple la
postulation la postulation c'est le fait
que quand on prend un avocat à marseille
et complète a lyon on est obligé de
payer un avocat à lyon pour déposer les
documents dans les affaires civiles
on subit la population ben oui bon
d'accord c'est une révolution ça la
question du travail le dimanche mais que
qui veut travailler le dimanche travail
le dimanche
voilà c'est tout vous donnez moi par
exemple les mères sont concernés par
voici que j'appliquerai le principe de
la liberté de choix quoi c'est ce qui
m'a été appliquée oui absolument
absolument d'accord mais alors là je
suis pas daccord forcément avec tout le
monde même dans mon propre mouvement
parce que il y a une volonté de défendre
le travail du dimanche que je peux
comprendre parce que c'est quand même
avec des manches c'est ça fait tellement
longtemps que le dimanche et est ancrée
dans notre horloge intérieur comme un
jour de repos que quelque part même dans
une société laïque on va en l'air
un élément de stabilité chronologique
voyez vous alors ça c'est un aspect de
la discussion qui me touche quand on
compte en avant cet argument je me dis
je me dis oui peut-être que si on fout
en l'air
cette espèce de plage du dimanche un ou
tous on arrive là pour pour souffler on
va encore accélérer le rythme de cette
société qui n'en peut plus et les moins
défendu par martine raynaud quelques
partis bourgeois et d'un autre côté je
me dis si les gens veulent gagner un peu
plus d'argent parce qu'ils en ont besoin
et travailler le dimanche pourquoi s'ils
le veulent les en empêcher vous admettez
des exceptions voilà je prends moi je
serai là je serai je serais pour la
règle de l'exception exceptionnel si je
puis me permettre ce pléonasme marine
martine aubry pardon parle de risa
martin alarie nourrir
martine aubry parle de régression
sociale oui parce qu'elle est la réelle
et très très religieuse un grand respect
pour le pour le dimanche
là je ne peux que la rejoindre dans ce
recours à la sacralité de ce jour qui
celui où un seigneur se repose dans la
tradition et ce qu'il faudrait
travailler le dimanche moyennant
compensation salariale
encore une fois joué moi je suis pour
que s'ils ont recours au travail du
dimanche
ça soit l'exception dans l'exception
avec toutes les conséquences qui
s'attache au caractère exceptionnel
d'une exception exceptionnel alors on va
avancer mercredi toujours une phrase de
marine le pen cette fois on parle de
marine le pen qui suit à suscite la
polémique et de condamnation unanime
alors écoutez
ces déclarations tu la torture est
excusable utilisation de la torture
parfois dans certaines circonstances y
avoir des cas permettez moi de vous dire
où quand une bombe
tic tac tic tac tic tac doit exploser
dans une heure ou dans deux heures et
accessoirement peut faire 200 ou 300
victimes civiles où il est utile de
faire parler la personne pour savoir où
et sous la torture
avec les moyens qu'on peut et un peu
plus tard la même marine le pen est à
nouveau interrogé sur ces propos elle
tente cette fois de se justifier cette
déclaration a fait l'objet d'une
interprétation tout à fait malveillantes
lorsque je suis interrogé et que l'on me
disait ce qu'on peut utiliser attendu
rigide j'en utilise les moyens qu'on
peut qu'on peut légalement utiliser la
torture est interdite en france
voilà alors marine le pen est revenu sur
ces propos alors vous avez dit le même
jour la torture oui mais comme recours
ultime pour sauver des vie marine le pen
s'est rétracté vous mais l'homme sait
comme la légitime défense bon moi je
suis contre la torture quand j'ai
défendu en correctionnelle le général
aussaresses j'ai dit que la torture que
les socialistes d'immoler françois
mitterrand avait installé en algérie
était ignoble mais si on est enfermé
tous les trois ici qui a claqué une
ordure qui a posé une bombe qu'on peut
pas sortir et qu'on cherche à savoir où
est la bombe
je préfère syst quand la belle à dire
oui la bombe
moi je n'ai pas envie exceptionnel
l'exception dans l'exception lire je
préfère je préfère que l'on malmène un
terroriste qui a posé une bombe
plutôt que si c'est vous qui êtes à
victimes c'est votre enterrement mais
encore une fois la la la torture c'est
ignoble et jean veut terriblement à guy
mollet j'en veux terriblement froid sans
mitterrand d'avoir ordonné des pleins
pouvoirs à l'armée en algérie parce que
la torture vous comprenez donc rien ne
peut la gestique la tortue rien ne la
justifie si ce n'est qu' on est pris au
piège
on n'appelle plus une seconde pour
sauver la vie on n'a plus une seconde
les serait ce vraiment efficace dans ces
cas extrêmes on l infini le drame c'est
que quand on autorise quand on autorise
l'exception extraordinaire on glisse et
c'est là où loulou l'acceptation est
difficile à assumer
parce qu'on donne quelques parades et
un permis et il faut être
il faut être vraiment se dire que c'est
dans les cas où l'autre va mourir quoi
voilà l'autre va mourir l'engin choix où
je laisse mourir l'innocent ou j'oblige
le terrorisme la sas a à dire oui l'ami
la bombe
voilà de quoi voir venir un petit peu
sur la façon de faire de moi j'arrivais
super cools seule façon de marine le pen
qui parle puis se rétracte c'est pas la
première fois c'était le cas notamment à
la fois sur le retour des otages encore
une fois là c'était sur les honneurs
maintenant on revient dessus permet le
propos non elle apporte une nuance
didactique
c'est qu'elle dit l'égalité elle parle
de l'égalité le terme qu'elles emploient
ces recours à des procédés légaux
or la torture en france n'est pas
légalisé donc on peut pas y recourir
bon moi je vous dis une chose la loi ne
l'autorisant pas je suis obligé de vous
laisser mourir je l avais peut-être mal
parlé au début malgré l adema penser
qu'elles avaient elles n'avaient pas
pointé la notion juridique
par exemple en israël la torture et et
codifier les réglementer puisqu'elle est
même surveillé je crois pour qu' il ya
une assistance médicale
la loi la loi ne permet pas le fait pas
on vous laisse mourir c'est une
maladresse j'aurais dit non c'est non
elle aurait dû préciser ce qu'est la
comp c'est quand la mesure d'un lac kivu
torture avec son micro c'est pas
forcément facile de placer chaque mort
alors je dis à votre sensible les
sénateurs se prononcent à leur tour sur
la reconnaissance d'un état palestinien
ils ont adopté une résolution socialiste
donc pour la reconnaissance d'un état
palestinien d'une courte majorité avec
des voix de droite
est ce que cette résolution peut avoir
des conséquences politiques en france
oui écoutez vos jours sont rendu compte
à l'assemblée moi j'ai j'ai appelé à
rejeter cette résolution
je me suis abstenu parce que j'ai voulu
marquer qu'un jour peut-être on pourra
avoir un état mais à l'heure actuelle
c'est un état terroriste avec le hamas
qui dans sa charte veut la disparition
d'israël et je me suis bien rendu compte
que ça crée une guerre communautaire
tous les socialistes ont fait ça
pourquoi je les dirai tribunes donc je
peux le répéter ici
ils veulent récupérer les voix des
banlieues c'est tout c'est une
résolution électoralement à j'y crois
vraiment oui oui oui c'est vrai c'est la
résolution n'a qu'un but politicien
c'est leur électorat de secours ils
n'ont pas vraiment ils font tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour plaire aux banlieues
pour complaire aux banlieues
je dirais même que lorsqu'on fait la
guerre aux crèches quelque part c'est
une manière de montrer que l'on veut
complaire aux banlieues est-ce que ce
est-ce que selon vous ce genre de
résolution
on l'avait assemblée au sénat y en a eu
d'autres aussi sur son ivg ça sert
quelque chose ces résolutions
l'assemblée nationale comme au sénat
sert à rien paris si ce n'est à diviser
hélas des communautés qu'on devrait
essayer de rapprocher de rassembler dans
dans le respect et l'amour de la nation
c'est un droit quand même pour les
parlementaires c'est quelque chose de
bien pour les parents s'exprimer mais
sur l'international c'est de faire des
résolutions tous les jeunes entre nous
est-ce qu'on avait besoin aujourd'hui
avec tous les problèmes que nous
rencontrons une résolution sur un sujet
qui divise bien évidemment que c'est pas
le bon moment
vous avez vu les agressions antisémites
quand j'ai eu quand tu as eu le
paroxysme du conflit entre israël et la
palestine
c'est tout derniers temps on a vu des
manifestations quand même bienvenu
drapeau de l'état islamique du levant il
y avait un drapeau des drapeaux bon on
est quand même dans une france qui est
très très tendu qui est qui et qui est
au bord de l'explosion communautaire bon
et on prend une résolution qui divise
encore plus leurs branchements que ce
n'était pas le monde cela renforce
communautarisme je pense que oui at il
des tensions vous comprenez parce que
quand même on a le hamas en palestine et
le hamas dans sa charte article 14 13 et
19 je crois si je me trompe pas bon il
appelle à l'éradication d'israël
or israël c'est quand même
l'occident avec toutes ces valeurs tout
sa démocratie israël représente les
valeurs de la démocratie même si
d'aucuns prétendent le contraire
et selon vous est ce que françois
hollande là se retrouve un petit peu
pieds et mains liés par cette résolution
et un peu pris au piège et les prix aux
pillages qu'est ce qui va faire
maintenant alors si si le parlement et
le sénat vote une résolution avec le
président s'en tape ça peut rester
symboliques sapin c'est symbolique
oui alors ça veut dire que ça à dire ça
ça veut ça veut dire qu'on fait joujou
quoi ça sert je voudrais c'est un sujet
aussi qui divise et qui suscite toujours
des polémiques ce sont deux députés qui
ont remis en fin de semaine leur rapport
sur la fin de vie au président de la
république chef de l'état qui voudraient
plutôt aboutir à une loi consensuelle
on va écouter françois hollande
évidemment en débat de ce thème hayes
gilbert collard sont aussi des
propositions équilibrées et réalistes
elle vise à apaiser la souffrance des
malades en fin de vie
respecter leur volonté dans
l'accompagnement vers la mort et donc
consacre le droit de mourir dans la
dignité
en accord avec le premier ministre je
demande à ce qu'un débat sur la base
d'une déclaration du gouvernement
titre de l'article 50-1 puissent être
organisés dès le mois de janvier
pratique de la sédation profonde et
continue
est ce que pour vous c'est l'euthanasie
sur le dire moi je pense que la loi
leonetti est une très bonne loi pour
être clair elle interdit l'acharnement
thérapeutique
voilà là la survie artificielle c'est
fini mais mais mais mais là on introduit
vers de rien
l'euthanasie bon alors certes rien l'air
de rien oui verdeaux rien parce que on
va encore partir dans un débat sociétal
ou encore passé un temps fou
pendant que l'économie va s'effondrer du
reste un à échanger des idées à ceux qui
veulent à tout prix défendre le droit à
la vie même jeu jusque dans l'épuisement
de la mort ça serait grave de modifier
la loi léonetti foule émergeaient la loi
léonetti elle est arrivée à un point
d'équilibré
pas d'acharnement thérapeutique mais si
on va au delà c'est quoi ce mode la ccc
qu'on se débarrasse de quelqu'un qui qui
qui qui qui n'est plus apparemment en
état de vivre mais on peut aussi sortir
d'un commun on peut dire on a vu des
gens plan entre guillemets le mode et
résurrection de toute l'histoire de la
médecine et est rempli de ces événements
brrr je dire que c'est quand même c'est
quand même grave quand tout dans une
société convergent vers la destruction
de ce qui a fait l'humanisme le respect
d'une chaîne locale
oui je pense que c'est le cas si on va
plus loin que la loi leonetti en risque
on risque d'aller d'aller fissurer le
noyau essentiel du respect qu'on doit à
la vie et il a aussi vous pensez que la
société peut encore se diviser comme on
l'avait vu à l'époque sur la fin du
mariage porté son choix ils ont aussi
c'est mon point de vue mais ils ont le
génie pour trouver des sujets qui
divisent le mariage pour tous maintenant
l'euthanasie mais je crois que c'est
fait exprès un vous pensez ab c'est
pourquoi ne débat pas des vrais sujets
mme économie qui s'effondre là ça prenne
vie qui s'en va
monsieur koala la famille est un vrai
sujet mais je dis pas que c'est pas vrai
sujet et non à la loi ne faites pas dire
ce que j'ai pas nulle part je viens vous
quand je dis que quand je veux dire par
là que la loi leonetti est une très
bonne loi
pourquoi pourquoi ne pas ne pas la
conserver voire même peut-être sur des
roues à l'améliorer
on imagine que le point par exemple
quelle pointure
sur les quais sur les questions
médicales qui aboutissent à la
définition si vous voulez de l'état où
on est en situation de l'acharnement
thérapeutique voilà vous savez que le
collège soit un collège de médecins qui
dessinent allemand voilà alors peut-être
aussi voir si on pourrait pas faire
intervenir un tiers expert qui
représenterait les intérêts de la
famille il ya plein de solutions je
deviens ça veut dire qu'on imagine que
au moment du débat à l'assemblée où
votre compte
bah oui oui sauf si les amendements qui
arrive modifier le texte de manière que
on est pas on n'est pas pour solution
soul et de se débarrasser quoi quand on
se débarrasse pas d'un être humain même
même si les graves ce qui compte c'est
qu'à un moment donné la souffrance de
celui ou de celle qu'on aime est
insupportable et qu'on ne peut plus rien
y faire et que le traitement qu'on
applique n'est qu'une volonté de faire
durer l'impossible ça il faut pas alors
j'ai eu un dollar on va passer à vous
sur les réseaux sociaux savoir si vous
êtes actif ou pas pour dresser tout de
suite votre e-réputation
ea street de vilaine est dans la place
alors que trouve-t-on bonjour astrid
jean-pierre que trouve-t-on sera sur
internet
quand on tape le nom de gilbert collard
et bien tapé gilbert collard dans un
moteur de recherche sur internet et vous
trouverez est bien en ce moment vous en
parliez à la une ces articles qui relève
vous propose sur la torture c'est la
preuve qu'ils ont été très consulté
enfin on tombe après sur un profil assez
typique pour un homme politique un site
internet vous avez un anglais blog sur
celui ci pour publier vos billets
d'humeur et d'ailleurs vous hébergez
même parfois ceux des autres comme en ce
moment celui de jean roucas qui fait un
parallèle entre l'interdiction des
crèches et la vie à l'elysée chacun son
humour
vous avez aussi une chaîne youtube que
vous alimentez depuis 2012 et sur
laquelle vous répondez deux fois par
mois à des sortes d'interviews organisé
par votre assistant parlementaire
un format qui rappelle celui de jean
marie le pen qui fait la même chose sur
son blog alors on peut vous poser la
question est ce que c'est de lui que
vous êtes inspiré lui qui fait d'accord
mais faut dire la vérité ça va mal ça
allait pas très bien l'avouer on a eu
une explication loyales à l'ancien alors
si à la audiard
alors vous faites en général 2000 3000
vu lui était quand même à 20000 alors
laissez-moi laisser voir arriver à 85
alors quand on tape gilbert collard
toujours sur le net l'une des premières
vidéos qui surgissent et celle de 2008
c'est une chanson vous devez sûrement
vous en souvenir à l'époque vous êtes
candidat aux municipales à vichy avec
l'étiquette divers droite on va écouter
un extrait de votre hymne de campagne
shi s'est endormi depuis tellement
d'années
dix neuf ans dans un lit
il faut la réveiller sur les charlet et
latéralité l'art lyrique émis vers
carnaval oublié alors peut-être première
question pourquoi avoir quitté le centre
alors d'abord est ce que vous savez qui
chantent
peut-être parce que si vous creusez vous
alors vous n'êtes pas posé la question
si quand on a préparé l'émission jeu
m'avait dit que c'était vous je vous ai
menti à voulez vous avoir au tournant
ces berlines air berlin air d'accord
vous savez qui c'est quand même bon il a
fait il est mort malheureusement un il
avait fait des spectacles sur victor
hugo il a fait la meuf fameuse chanson
lounge oublier le titre qui a fait le
tour du monde c'est assez formidable sur
le centre pour le mot l'avait quittée
j'habitais au centre c'est encore des
divers droite j'ai dit non
j'étais au parti radical valoisien et
quand j'ai été candidat il a refusé de
soutenir
on pourrait finalement alors alors
j'étais un gars droite soit faute de
pouvoir être au parti radical et je me
suis vite cassé de ce parti de faux
derche qui vous poignardent dans le dos
pour pourquoi pour récupérer s'il joue
deux quoi bon voila j'ai fait le tour
des photos sur les réseaux sociaux
j'ai d'ailleurs vous êtes très très
apparemment c'est pas que les berlines
rbc j'ai vu l'article sera pas relayée
ah bon vous êtes très cuite et vous même
vous avez une page facebook très
alimenté qui suscite beaucoup de
commentaires parfois négatifs et vous
les laissez votre combat du vendredi ce
sont les crèches interdite au nom de la
laïcité dans les mairies ou les conseils
généraux et c'est un petit peu votre
combat du moment et vous utiliser les
réseaux sociaux un pour vous faire
entendre sur ce sujet vous agrégée aux
communautés déjà existantes vous relayer
des initiatives comme touche pas à ma
crèche un moyen de toucher du public
nouveau qui peuvent adhérer à vos idées
vous
et plus de 22000 followers sur twitter
vous êtes inscrit depuis deux ans depuis
votre élection à l'assemblée
mais si l'on regarde chez l'autre député
enfin chez la députée du front national
votre acolyte marion maréchal-le pen
elle est à 162 milles
comment expliquez vous cette différence
parce que moi je suis un petit un
modeste alors qu'ils ont dit oui tu vois
je suis partisane à moi je twitte moi
même et je avec modération avec
modération
ouais lui aimait mes tweets sont repris
souvent dur est de chercher si on était
sympa oui vous vous direz qu'en revanche
du point de vue qualitatif je suis fière
de ce le plus souvent repris et bien le
boss omeyer traitons pas tout de suite
regardé c'est encore sur les crèches
comme quoi c'est un sujet porteur pour
le rassemblement bleu marine le voilà
plus de 300 retweete crèche de noël
interdite au nom de la laïcité culture
histoire rêve d'enfant tout disparaît
dans mon pays la france avec les crèches
c'est vraiment le sujet c'est que les
jus d'humour c'est sinon c'est que ça
signifie ça signifie qu'on a qu'on a
conservé grâce
grâce à dieu avec un une signification
général la sensibilité de notre histoire
où la force de vouloir y toucher
ça va finir par mal se passer bon alors
c'est ça
cette affaire de la crèche elle est très
significative de la sensibilité heurter
des gens aujourd'hui et c'est ça qu'il
faut voir climat moi je moi j'étais dans
une relation
j'étais dans une réunion l'autre jour où
il y avait un maire socialiste et un
président de conseil général socialiste
et c'était c'était un repas où il y
avait des anciens et jeu chacun avait
son discours et moi dans mon discours je
leur ai dit je vous souhaite une bonne
crèche de noël tout le monde a applaudi
y compris le maire et y compris le
président du conseil général pour les
crèches merci astrid de nous avoir
éclairé sur la e-réputation d'autres
invités ans passés au plus de l'hebdo
tout fait
les chaînes parlementaires vous propose
un film ça s'appelle la désintégration
pourrez le voir pendant les fêtes de
noël date de 2000 où il prend encore
plus de sens depuis quelques mois en
tout cas c'est une chronique sur la
montée de l'islam fondamentaliste dans
nos vies de regarder ces extraits
proposés par simon barbare et des
musulmans en prière dans un espace vert
d'une banlieue lilloise
la scène d'ouverture du film la
désintégration donne tout de suite le
ton
voilà une fiction qui n'hésite pas à
s'emparer des thèmes les plus clivants
de notre société celui d'une
manifestation religieuse dans un espace
public et bien au delà celui du repli
identitaire qui conduit certains jeunes
français dans l'engrenage radical du
jihad
trois jeunes ali nico et nasser victime
d'un sentiment d'exclusion sont
recueillis par djamel un prédicateur
intégristes bien loin de l'image du
barbu hystérique son discours fait alors
dangereusement écho dans leur conscience
des français soit disant elle fait des
études vous êtes instruire vous avez
droit à rien quand as tu besoin de vos
parents pour amasser des époux belle et
tonnerre de marteau piqueur la partir du
moment où vous ou d'aspirer à faire
autre chose là ils veulent plus de vous
pourquoi le réalisateur philippe faucon
n'hésite pas à s'emparer de la question
sociale pour en faire l'unique moteur de
ce repli identitaire le chômage la
pauvreté les discriminations telles sont
les ennemis de la république
aucune ségrégation formule est juste une
habitude diffuse d'exclusion inavoués tu
peux faire tous les efforts que tu veux
ces pipes et avance c'est un racisme
c'est tous des bâtards de raciste ici
c'est une france des mères mais toi t'es
pas raciste peut-être si si je suis
raciste ou c'est pourquoi parce que tel
pour devenir définira si on est tous des
racistes
tu as passé toute sa vie à répéter
célibataire c'est raciste qu'est ce que
tu fais d'autres la justesse des acteurs
professionnels et amateurs du film
apporte le poids nécessaire à cette
analyse d'un modèle républicain dépassé
métrage avoir sur public sénat le lundi
22 décembre à 17h15
comment parler vous à ces jeunes qui
peuvent tomber par dizaines dans cet
engrenage aller vers l'islam radical
viennent rarement se confesser ammoura
je vous le dis tout de suite mais je
crois que à l'instant où ils ont fait le
choix c'est trop tard donc ces avancées
avant qu'on doit travailler et en dehors
de l'école je vois rien d'autre
franchement donc c'est un échec telle
école ah oui après le charbon c'est un
échec que de l'école et du discours
républicain on n'a pas été capable de
tenir un vrai discours républicain
capable de fâcher capable de mécontenter
mais qui disent le réel ça c'est permis
ça c'est des cinq ans à l'école pour
vous ça commence à l'école et andré dans
une école qui note dans une école qui
fait respecter la discipline dans une
école qui fait respecter le civisme dans
une école qui fait respecter le pays la
nation histoire vous comprenez dans une
école qui donne envie d'aimer le pays
qui vous donne tout d'un mot lazare
ponticelli lé plus vieux poilus morts à
101 ans quand on lui a dit pourquoi vous
êtes vous engagé volontairement à l'âge
de 16 ans la france m'a tout donné je
lui dois tout merci gilbert collard
l'invité de parlement hebdo on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine bonne
semaine à tous